so it's apparently terrible to tell
Millennials to save their money or
invest their money these days on Monday
news broke worldwide that are not
sterling in real estate developer Tim
garner had explained that one of the
secrets to financial success was saving
and investing rather than spending quote
when I was buying my first home I wasn't
buying smashed avocado for 19 bucks in
for coffees at $4 each corner explained
or at a point now where the expectations
of younger people are very very high
they want to eat out every day they want
to travel to Europe every year I think
until this generation realizes that the
people that owned homes today work very
very hard for it saved every dollar does
everything they could to get up the
prospering ladder they won't get ahead
you might have to buy an investment
property first you might have to share
with mum or dad you might have to buy
with a friend but you've got to get your
foot in the door and you've got to
slowly get up the ladder this was
apparently a terrible thing to say never
come between a millennial and her
avocado toast
but obviously Gerner was talking about
the choice by some young people to spend
repeatedly on lifestyle rather than
saving he didn't restrict his comments
to the rather silly example of avocado
toast he talked about European vacations
- which are a little bit more expensive
naturally to avoid the implications of
groaners correct statement the New York
Times fact-checked them they wrote quote
the truth is even if Millennials assume
the eating out habits of baby boomers it
would take around 113 years before they
could afford a down payment on a home
assuming a 20% down payment on the
median price for a home in the u.s.
$315,000 in March 2017 and a one percent
yearly yields rate the average price of
a single avocado in March was 125
according to the Haas avocados one
Twitter user Norah Viet Timmons
calculated that a serving of avocado
toast cost her about 165 or 177 896
thousands of the average price of a home
in Brooklyn but does the New York Times
have any decent advice for Millennials
other than snarking about avocados of
course not here is the fact everybody is
spending more now but Millennials cannot
afford to do so because they are younger
and poorer while the New York Times
acknowledges that all generations of
Americans are eating out more for
example it fails to evaluate whether
younger people can afford to do so in a
way older people can when we were
younger my wife and I didn't need out
nearly as much as we do now we also had
a lot less money overall
young people are racking up debt much
faster these days here's ABC news from
several years ago quote the percentage
of students holding at least one credit
card in 2001 rose 24% since 1998
according to the latest figures from
student loan provider Nelly may the
median debt level among
card-carrying undergrads rose to $1,770
in 2001 from 1236 dollars in 2000 an
indicator that more students are using
their cards regularly it may not be
paying off the balances each month
here's CNBC from 2015 more than half of
millenials people aged 18 to 34 reported
a credit score below 670 Millennials are
even turning to payday loans and
pawnshops to put cash in the bank
Millennials aren't getting married or
buying homes thanks to cost and they're
not putting money in the stock market
but they are spending money on travel
some millennial money trouble comes from
the global financial downturn of course
but to neglect personal decision-making
in terms of investing is a mistake
why wouldn't investors tell kids to save
up because it might hurt their feelings
and suggests that they have agency in
their own lives when I told the group of
students in a downtrodden public school
okay around high school then in a free
country like America permanent poverty
is a function of making poor financial
decisions the high school principal
actually dismissed the students telling
me that too many of their parents were
impoverished and thus might feel
insulted the problem here isn't least
talked about avocado toast if the people
don't want to hear the truth their lives
are in their hand and if they don't like
their financial situations perhaps they
should start by examining their own
decisions i'm ben shapiro this is the
venture hero show
all righty another day another quasi
scandal we will talk about two big
stories one from the right and one from
the left and everybody seems to be
buying into and what is true and what is
not before we do I want to say thank you
to our sponsors over at bull and branch
so board branch sheets are the best
sheets that you can buy on the market
they are fantastic
I bought bull and brand cheats on my own
after I got my complimentary set and the
fact is that they are so good that I
cannot sleep on any other sheets now
that's why I bought more sets of bull
and branches they are so comfortable
they're basically made from the finest
material I don't know anything about
thread count I don't know anything about
what makes a sheet great other than what
feels good to me and I can tell you that
bull and branch cheats feel the best of
any sheet I've ever used you use promo
code Bennett bull and branch calm and
get $50 off your first set of sheets
Plus free shipping you are going to
sleep better on bull and branch cheats I
know because I do and I am NOT a good
sleeper again it's bol el and branch
calm promo code Ben they are may they're
ethically made also so that means that
they're they're made with you know by
they're not made in some sweatshop
somewhere they are SuperDuper
comfortable and they are much more
affordable than you think and when you
think about the fact you're going to be
sleeping on these every night you have
to understand that a little bit of cost
goes a long way the kind of sheets that
they sell normally would retail for like
a thousand dollars they are not a
thousand dollars a couple hundred bucks
will get you set a bull and branch each
50 bucks off your first set of sheets
Plus free shipping when you go to bull
and branch calm and use that promo code
Ben it's 100% organic cotton fantastic
product full and branch calm promo code
Ben let them know that we sent you an
get 50 bucks off your first set of
sheets plus that free shipping ok so the
big story of the day there are two big
stories of the day one from the right
and one from the left and I want to
discuss them both in detail I'm going to
start with the one from the right
because I think that there's more to
talk about than the one from the left
that's the one that's leading on the
newspapers so the one from the right
that is being pumped by Fox News it's
being pumped by Drudge is being pumped
by Breitbart news today is this story
about a guy named Seth rich so Seth rich
is a former was a former member of the
DNC he was a guy who worked at the DNC
and he was shot back in during the
middle of the election cycle he was
killed on the street and there was a lot
of suspicion about that because well the
police had been investigating it as
an armed robbery gone wrong nothing was
stolen like a few thousand dollar
necklace on him as well it was left on
him and so there are a lot of
accusations that this was actually an
assassination so last night five cc5
reports that a private investigator
named rod wheeler had revealed that his
investigation into the murder of DNC
staffer rich quote shows there was some
degree of email exchange between seth
rich and wikileaks
I do believe the answers to murder who
murdered Seth rich sits on his computer
on a shelf at the DC police or FBI
headquarters so the accusation here is
it the WikiLeaks group was actually
getting the DNC emails not from the
Russians but from an insider at the DNC
that the DNC was basically they had a
mole and the Mobile's area said about
Bernie Sanders losing and so he was
sending all sorts of information
thousands upon thousands of emails to
WikiLeaks and then he was shot over it
presumably by somebody associated with
the DNC or the Hillary Clinton campaign
is one of the right would have you
believe or at least the conspiratorial
right would have you believe it would
also debunk a lot of the stories about
how Russia was the one hacking the DNC
it would turn out that it was an inside
job from somebody who was presumably
just a Bernie Sanders supporter it would
be more of an Edward Snowden situation
not necessarily a spy situation which
would change a lot of the Trump Russia
talk Fox News has now reported that an
anonymous federal investigator said
forty four thousand fifty three emails
and seventeen thousand 761 attachments
between DNC committee leaders spanning
January 2015
through late May 2016 or transferred
from rich to the director of WikiLeaks
Gavin McFadden who's also recently
deceased
they say the anonymous federal
investigator had said that so we have an
anonymous source saying something when
the family has denied these reports and
slams wheeler for violating
confidentiality basically they released
a statement that says that there is no
evidence and no email suggesting
WikiLeaks links their statements as
we've seen through the past year of
unsubstantiated claims he no facts we
have seen no evidence we've been
approached with no emails and only
learned about this one contacted by the
press even if tomorrow an email was
found it is not high enough bar of
evidence to prove any interactions as
emails can be altered that we seem that
those interested in pushing conspiracies
will stop at nothing to do so we our
family who's committed to facts not take
evidence that surfaces every few months
to fill the void and distract law
enforcement and the general public from
finding Seth's murderers the services of
the private investigator who spoke to
press was offered to the rich family and
paid
by a third party and contractually was
barred from speaking to press or anyone
outside of law enforcement or the family
are must explicitly authorized by the
family so here is the bottom line on
this particular story we just don't know
enough at this point we don't know the
family obviously saying they don't
believe this
the FBI has not released a statement on
any of this the DC Police denies all of
this with all of that said people are
jumping on to the anonymous sourcing
here and they are jumping onto this this
p.i this private investigator who has a
bit of a sketchy history they're jumping
on this to basically suggest that this
is the big scandal of the day is that
Seth rich was murdered because he was
sending DN C emails to WikiLeaks so
here's the bottom line not enough
evidence to say one way or another not
enough evidence to say one way or
another we still don't know who did the
murder we know that the family objects
to this we know that the P AI is shaky
and the FBI has not released a statement
when more information comes out then we
can make a judgement unfortunately
people aren't waiting to make a
judgement they're just jumping on it and
this shows I think that confirmation
bias has absolutely seeped into every
aspect of news coverage right now people
are seeing a story they're deciding
whether they liked the story or not and
they're believing it based on whether
they like it or not they're seeing a
story that's filled with anonymous
sources like this anonymous FBI guy and
they're deciding whether they like the
anonymous source based on what the
anonymous source is saying they're
looking at a story like this and they're
saying well sure the family says this
was leaked in violation of
confidentiality but leaks are okay
because we think it's an important story
so now flip the script and we're going
to talk about the story from the left
okay so the Washington Post reports last
night that President Trump during that
meeting with the Russians that we talked
about last week in the day after he
fires FBI director James Comey the
Washington Post reports that he has this
meeting with derogate Kiselyov who's the
ambassador from Russia and who is a
spymaster by pretty much every available
piece of information as well as the
Foreign Minister Sergey Lavrov he has
this meeting behind closed doors there
are no American press people at this
meeting it's just the Russians who are
there and Russian press coverage
apparently and according to The
Washington Post he revealed that quote
highly classified information to the
Russian Foreign Minister and ambassador
in a White House meeting last week
according to current and former US
officials who said Trump's disclosures
jeopardized a critical source of
intelligence on the Islamic state the
information the president relayed had
been provided by a US
through an intelligence sharing
arrangement considered so sensitive that
details have been withheld from allies
and tightly restricted even within the
US government's and officials the
partner had not given the United States
permission to share the material with
Russia an official said Trump's decision
to do so in dangerous cooperation from
an ally that has access to the inner
workings of the Islamic state
after Trump's meeting senior White House
officials took steps to contain the
damage placing calls to the CIA and the
National Security Agency this is code
word information said a US official
familiar with the matter using
terminology that refers to one of the
highest classification levels used by
American spy agencies the Washington
Post by the way says that they have the
information but they're not going to
print the information because it'd be
unsafe to print the information that the
post is withholding most plot details
including the name of the city that
apparently chrome mentioned at the
urging of officials who warned that
revealing them would jeopardize
important intelligence capabilities so
the story is basically there are a
couple of anonymous sources inside the
Trump White House who leaked that Trump
had revealed highly classified
information to the Russians so a couple
things out of the way first and foremost
one even if from tonight it's not
criminal okay the president gets to
decide what's classified and what's not
classified article two of the
Constitution says nothing about
classification standards have not being
impacted by the president the president
can decide to declassify things as fast
as the president wants so Trump into
anything criminal that said if the
Democrats decide or if the Republicans
decide Congress can impeach for stuff
that's not criminal so this is still not
great stuff I mean just because the
president did something legal doesn't
mean something good point number two
yes Democrats are hypocrites when it
comes to leaks the Democrats leaked all
the time they leaked classified
information to our enemies on a routine
basis in 2011 for example this did not
get a lot of attention even those big
story in 2011 Joe Biden and the vice
president revealed that it was SEAL Team
6 that had killed Osama bin Laden and
there were members of SEAL Team 6
families who felt that he put a target
on their back by revealing this
information publicly let me briefly
acknowledge tonight's distinguished
honorees Admiral Jim stavridis is a is a
real deal he could tell you more about
and understands the incredible
phenomenal the just almost unbelievable
capacity of his Navy SEALs and what they
did
last last Sunday okay so and there he
was you know spilling classified
information and it ended up actually
being quite tragic because SEAL Teams
were then targeted by al-qaeda
apparently but that was not a big
scandal on the left or among the media
obviously the Obama administration also
leaked information from our allies
repeatedly particularly from Israel they
leaked information over and over and
over about Israeli plans to strike the
Iranian nuclear facilities in an attempt
to stop Israel from doing all of that so
those two points out of the way one it's
not criminal to the Obama administration
did stuff like this all the time it is
still bad it's so a really bad thing if
the President of the United States
cannot be trusted with classified
information if he's just going out there
and saying things to people openly
because he's got an ego problem which is
supposedly what happened you got a
problem so apparently what happened is
that when Trump described measures the
US has taken or is contemplating to
counter the threat of Isis including
military operations in Iraq and Syria as
well as other steps to tighten security
Trump cast the countermeasures and
whistle terms it can you believe the
world we live in today
isn't it crazy so he was just supposedly
showing off now here is the problem okay
so the the White House denies the story
but there are a couple of different
types of denial sadena Powell was the
deputy national security adviser
she's an eyes of the story wholesale she
says none of this ever happened none of
this ever happened and then HR McMaster
who is the national security adviser who
has a high level of trust with
conservatives as well he should he comes
out and he gives a statement a sixty
second statement last night without
taking any questions and here's what he
said last night about this Washington
Post story there's nothing that the
president takes more seriously than the
security of the American people the
story that came out tonight as reported
is false the president and the Foreign
Minister reviewed a range of common
threats to our two countries including
threats to civil aviation at no time at
no time were intelligence sources or
methods discussed and the president did
not disclose any military operations
that were not already publicly known to
other senior officials who were present
including the Secretary of State
remembered of eating the same way and
have said so they're on the record
account should outweigh those of an
anonymous sources and I was in the room
it didn't happen thanks everybody okay I
was in the room it didn't happen now the
question has become what does it mean
because the fact is that what HR
McMaster is saying here is sort of a
denial like I just want to be exact
about this it's sort of denial and sort
of not okay so it's a denial of things
that the Washington Post never claims
the Washington Post never claimed that
Trump had revealed intelligence sources
or methods what the Washington Post
claims is that Trump had said something
about a particular city where there was
an Isis operation taking place and the
fact that we knew about it endangered
one of our sources that's basically the
Washington Post claimed McMaster is
denying something the Washington Post
never claimed there this morning HR
McMaster came out and he said something
different which we'll get to in just one
second but first I want to say thank you
to our sponsors over at legacy box so if
you are if you are worried about
preserving your lifetime memories and
you should be because the fact is if
they're moldering in a cardboard box
somewhere in the back your garage it's
possible that bugs can get in there rats
can get in there they degrade over time
and it can be a flood bottom you're
never gonna pull them out anyway because
there are no film reels that's what
legacy boxes for so you take all those
old memories all the pictures all of the
film reels all of the tapes and you send
them into legacy box comm and legacy box
puts them all on a DVD or a thumb drive
so that you can access those memories
anytime you want you load legacy box
it's a natural box with your old tapes
fill in pictures audio recordings and
you send it back to them they put they
put barcodes on every piece of the
information you send to them so you can
track it throughout the process they
send them back to you in a couple weeks
on DVD or on a thumb drive they take
care of everything everything is safe
they provide updates every step of the
process of recorder million families
have used legacy box comm right now if
you go to legacy box comm slash Ben you
get 40% discount on your order again go
to legacy box comm slash Ben you get a
40% discount on your order there's
nothing that's more important than
preserving those memories and it will
also make it easier if god forbid
something happens to your house all you
have to just grab the thumb drive you
don't even have to upload it to your
computer all you have to do is grab
something small instead of trying to
slap boxes out in the middle of an
earthquake legacy box comm slash man
this is something you're definitely
gonna want to do it makes a great
Mother's Day or Father's Day gifts for
sure
40% discount on your order when you use
legacy box comm slash been so McMaster
goes out there he denies it sort of Dena
Powell denies it completely secretary of
state Reps Tillerson echos McMaster
statement and then president Trump
just cannot help himself he just cannot
help himself he gets up this morning and
he goes on Twitter any tweet as
president I wanted to share with Russia
at an openly scheduled White House
meeting which I have the absolute right
to do facts pertaining to terrorism and
airline flight safety humanitarian
reasons plus I want Russia to greatly
step up their fight against Isis and
terrorism so he had his entire team go
out there and say it never happened and
then he goes out there and he says it
happened but it's okay that I did it
okay that's not the same case that's not
the same case and that's open to debate
because we don't know what the
information is so how are we ever
supposed to confirm or deny that what he
said was okay to say we have no way of
knowing that if it really was okay then
presumably the White House could do
something very easy they could just
release the transcript of the
conversation which they have mcmaster
came out this morning and he said yeah
Trump said something but none of us
found an objectionable it wasn't really
a big deal McMaster said the president
was not even aware of where the
information came from
he wasn't briefed on the source and
Method they couldn't revealed the source
and Method okay well but that wasn't the
claim I mean the claim was not that he
was briefed on the source and Method or
that he revealed the source and Method
the claim was that he revealed
confidential information classified
information that can actually put
somebody in the line of fire that was
essentially what he what the claim was
and McMaster is now saying and Trump is
now saying that it's not a big deal what
he revealed okay but there are two
problems with this one that's subjective
so it's possible that our allies could
look at that and they could say well he
may not think it's problem but I think
it's a problem I'm never giving from
classified information again there was a
report from earlier this year that the
Israelis had stopped giving Trump
classified information because they were
afraid the Trump was just going to spill
it on the record somewhere so there's
that there's also the problem with okay
well if it really was not that big a
deal why don't you just declassify it
and why just released the conversation
again why is any of this a big deal
because it goes to character and
president Trump is having a problem of
character inside his administration he's
having a problem of character inside his
administration and he's undermining
people inside his administration whose
credibility he needs to uphold he needs
to uphold McMasters credibility and it
doesn't look good when McMaster comes
out last night says the story is false
and then the next day comes back and
says well I really said that most of the
story was false you know the parts that
weren't there but it's kind of true but
it's not a big deal this is the same
thing that happened last week if you
recall all the way back to last week my
god time just has stopped moving
and last week the President of the
United States trotted out half his
administration including vice president
pence to say that all of this that was
going on with the FBI director Comey had
been spurred by the Deputy Attorney
General sending water and then two days
later he went on national news and he
said no no no I was going to do it
anyway it had nothing to do with that
after his entire press team had gone out
and blamed it on Rod Rosenstein so the
big problem here is from the big problem
here is Trump and the reason that this
is a problem is because if you don't
have credibility with the American
people then you're going to have a hard
time pushing legislation you're going to
have a hard time wing allies you're
gonna have a hard time doing the things
the president actually needs to do
you're also going to be undercutting
your case for how how careful you are
about classified information so I mean
the left is having a field day with this
of course and you know they were it
doesn't make them not dishonest they are
dishonest but the left is having a field
day the point here is that the left is
going to be left you knew they were
going to be the left okay are you going
to be the one who decides to step on
every rake in a hundred mile radius it's
just foolish
you know Trump spent half of this
campaign talking about how Hillary had
not protected classified information
here's a montage from talking about it
over and over and over again the
Secretary of State was extremely
careless and negligent in handling our
classified secrets she lied about
passing on classified information right
in my administration I'm going to
enforce all laws concerning the
protection of classified information she
said she said nothing more classified a
total lie we can have someone in the
Oval Office who doesn't understand the
meaning of the word confidential or
classified okay again you spend the
entire campaign saying this and then you
undercut your own case because you can't
stay off Twitter and because you can't
keep your mouth shut
it's a problem of character and that
does have ramifications now I could sit
here and make everybody happy if I just
dashing the left and that's very easy to
do but here's the problem the same
people on the right who are buying the
Seth rich story hook line and sinker
which we don't have verified yet are
saying this is all fake news now even
though Trump has already sort of
confirmed it and conversely people on
the Left who are dismissing the center
rich stuff are immediately buying
everything about this story before
anything has sort of been confirmed
the confirmation bias in the news is
extraordinarily strong there's more
information that the Washington Post
story is true at this point because
Trump has quasi confirmed it and chose
McMaster then there is a separate story
is true but I would just like to point
out the inconsistency that everybody
seems to be suffering from and
evaluating these stories anonymous
sources are anonymous sources until
there's confirmation leaks are bad leaks
are really bad but the leak is not
actually the story and you don't get to
say that the leak is the big story if
you spent the entire campaign saying
that WikiLeaks was not the story it was
the contents of the WikiLeaks that
actually mattered this is really not
good stuff but I want to talk a little
bit more about how Trump can fix this
because actually really easy to fix if
you would just listen and stop it's easy
to fix and we'll talk about democratic
overexpress we have to deconstruct some
culture but for this listen guys you
know I wish every day I could come on
here and talk about the great stuff
Trump is doing but he needs to do good
things in order for me to talk about it
so again I just hope and pray that he
does for the rest of the podcast go over
to Daley wired.com $8 a month gets his
subscription to daily wire if you want
an annual subscription that you can get
a free copy of the Arroyo fictional film
set on our southern border about a
rancher trying to defend his land from
drug cartels using his land as a
thoroughfare really good movie it is to
get that annual subscription or $8 a
month gets you the normal subscription
at daily wire.com you can part the
mailbag in a couple of days we will
answer all your questions or if you just
want to listen later head over to iTunes
or SoundCloud and make sure you
subscribe and download and leave us a
review we always appreciate it we are
the number one conservative podcast in
America
[Music]
you